hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast what can we learn from a large
gene expression data sets we are
delighted to bring this educational web
seminar presented by blathers I am Judy
O'Rourke and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problems through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker Jeremy Miller
PhD dr. Miller is a scientist at the
Allen Institute for brain science he
joined the Allen Institute in 2011 to
help with computational data analysis
for the Allen human brain atlas project
and has extended it today to
transcriptional atlases of the
developing human and non-human primate
brain dr. Miller is currently interested
in using large-scale gene expression
data to characterize cell types of the
mammalian brain and also identifying
molecular pathways unique to humans he
received his PhD in neuroscience from
UCLA where he studied gene expression
changes in the brain in Alzheimer's
disease and normal aging I will now turn
it over to dr. Miller for his
presentation thank you very introduction
and thanks for inviting me to us today
and thank everyone for listening um as
Judy mentioned I'll talk about what we
can learn from large gene expression
data sets I'm using data that's really
accessible from the sound Institute
websites so overall my talk today is
going to basically see or I will give
you some descriptions of what a few of
these atlases are some
information about how people typically
use these atlases and then I'll talk
about three topic from the analysis that
we've looked into that we've sounds very
interesting related to some some title
we think are interesting biological
questions so the first one will be in
humans where he found that genes
involved in brain function and
dysfunction tend to show consistent
expression patterns between adult human
brains
the second topic will also involve the
mouse brain outlets where we're looking
at convergent and divergent gene
expression patterns between the human in
the mouth frame and the third part will
be looking at NIH blueprint non-human
primate habits where we find that gene
expression patterns at different layers
of cortex change dramatically with age
so this is a main portal for the F on
brain atlas and so the first part is
going to be looking at the human brain
atlas which is highlighted in yellow
there's also an interesting case study
which looks at differential expression
between brain regions which you could
also could - you're interested
so the åland human brain ours is a
multi-modal ours which consists of
several parts there's an imaging MRI
component there's a large format and
comical reference data there's whole
brain histology including missiles and
these are what he sits out here with
what was used to delineate the different
regions of the brain for the micro es
microarray component which I'll talk
about in a second
and there's some medium-format
anatomical reference data including in
situ hybridization of in certain area to
the brain of over a thousand genes the
main component that I'll talk about is
the transcriptional microarray component
which consists of data from six frames
the first two brains have both
hemispheres were sampled and when we
found a very few if any differences
between hemispheres the left four brands
were only example
a single hemisphere and within each
hemisphere if there's data from about
500 different microarrays
spanning two to three hundred plus brain
regions and so and so these brain
regions were taken by experts anonymous
looking at these histology data and
generating this reference and high
precision and anatomical reference that
could be used for laser micro expression
there's a soft cortical areas and then
just macro actually the new portal areas
so the way that that was is generally
used if you can go on on and look up a
particular gene of interest so in this
case I show even that for PC bh8 or the
red it's represents high expression and
the green screen represents lower
expression so this would see a gene
where the expression is high in
hippocampus for example another common
use for this Alice would be to look for
genes that are differentially expressed
between different areas of the brain so
that's the case study that I was talking
about it was shown here and if we're
looking for games that are
differentially except between the ca3
field hippocampus and the Globus
pallidus turns out that PC DHA is one of
the top lines but we wanted to look at
with something slightly different that
uses pretty much all of the data
together and that is to ask for about
consistency between grains so most
studies of gene expressions look at a
one or two different things so control
versus disease one brain region versus
another across a large number of
individuals and we have it's sort of its
inverse thing here that's where there's
a lot of different brain regions
throughout for small number of
individuals so we wanted to see if we
could find genes that are a consistent
expression patterns across the small
number of individuals a lot of these
brain regions and so the way that we
tested this if we define a metrics that
we call differential stability which is
the average Pearson correlation across
brain regions for each pair of brains so
I have again
as an example here in these are class
these bar plots represent the average
expression for eight about a hundred
regions for all the samples from each of
them strains so this is range one
through six the height of the bar
represents expression in a given region
and what you can see is just by eye
these spots look very similar which
means that the correlation between
grains across regions for this gene
would be high and therefore this metric
for differential stability or for
consistency between grains would be high
so this would represent the gene is very
consistent between grains and what we
can do is we can then rank all the genes
in the genome based on how well how
consistent they are between grains or
their amount of difference or stability
and so what we did is we hypothesized
the genes would show this consistent
pattern in between grains that they
would be a particularly important for
function and dysfunction regardless of
their particular pattern in brain or the
expression levels that they have overall
and so the way we tested this as sort of
a first test was to just search in
PubMed abstracts for the word brain
along with all the genes with it's the
particular gene symbols and so it's this
plot shows is the Green Line is the
genes ranked based on a difference of
civility from their the most consistent
on the Left released consistent on the
right and then the blue line shows the
percentage of genes with that level of
differential stability that could be
found along with brain in PubMed and
there's a pretty good correlation which
basically just shows that the more
stable Edina than those in the genomes
are more related to brain it is and that
sort of qualitative life and so to get
if it's in a more quantitative way we
looked at this the top ten percent of
gene for the top decile genes with the
highest differential stability and then
similarly for the 10th the 20th
percentile twenty to thirty percentile
and so on and we looked for enrichment
of each of those deciles
again functional categories
types a transcription factor binding
sites in ontology terms genes associated
with micro RNAs or drug targets and what
we found is the top decile that's 10% of
genes with the most consistent
expression the same brain so it's tend
to be the ones that are far the most
enriched for all of these difference on
categories suggesting these are related
functions more so than other genes until
we exponents look at dysfunctions and so
the way we look at dysfunction was to
get a set of genes that are related to
different diseases and disorders until
we got this feed list from the Oxford
database which has compiled about 2,500
flips of genes related to different
diseases of both the brain and of other
organs in the body society in general
and we compared all of those gene lists
against the differential stability of
the genes in that list and so a random
set of genes would show up as the bottom
pink bar shows salty and so they're
basically scattered evenly across the
arms the genomes but what we find is
that genes related to diseases of the
brain such as generic mental disorders
schizophrenia epilepsy dementia foods
and up higher differential stability and
it's in a random set of genes which is
shown by these blue bars being shifted
to the right off the p-value shown in
red however when we do this for deep
frigidly that's not related to the gray
and they do not show this shift and so
it's really what we could say from this
is it it's genes with a most consistent
expression in the brain tend to be
related to brain or later diseases but
not so much other diseases so it is a
brain specific phenomenon that we're
fighting here so the next question that
we wanted to ask is so if we believe now
that these genes are related to function
and dysfunction one could imagine that
either the pattern itself doesn't really
matter it's just effective working
system that's a hypothesis or it could
be that
there's a particular pattern or to such
a high expression in cortex across
grades or high expression in hippocampus
that matter more than others and so to
get it that's what we did is we
performed weighted you encode expression
network analysis and the basic idea here
is to take all the genes in the genome
and groups image patterns of genes that
have similar expression patterns and
then we wanted to check the to whether a
high differential the genes with high
differential stability was spread out
across all these patterns or for sort of
selective to a handful of these
different statuses and so a little
background on lady gene co-expression
network analysis basically the way it
works is you take the expression level
of every single gene across all of the
samples of interest in this case it
would be this brain region the
expression level on average in the brain
regions you then paralyze correlate all
of the genes together which gives you a
correlation matrix this is then
converted to a topological burlap which
is some more biologically robust metrics
it's very similar to correlation and
basically asked how close neighbors of
one gene with patterns are to the
neighbors and other genes from that you
can hierarchically cluster genes to
group them into these different patterns
and then ask which what are the patterns
and which genes are in each of the
different patterns and so in our case we
want to keep track of the differential
stability of the genes in each of the
different patterns and so when we did
this that's what is next by showing we
find 32 robust patterns which are shown
in this top left box standard ran
basically shows the genes along the x
axis and there through module grouping
or which pattern they refer them in
these colored bars below that there's
one example other patterns which you can
see is high-end stratum slightly lower
in cerebral cortex and low and most of
the subcortical structures and this is
one example home it also has very robust
expression patterns across
trains on the right it could be all
three to his pattern and it doesn't
really matter for this what's the
difference
regions are but the important point is
that some of these patterns show higher
regional susceptibility to a particular
brain regions on some of them show
specificity for a handful of brain
regions and some of them show sort of a
more variable pattern across the grain
so there's a good mix of expression
patterns and most genes fall into one of
these 32 saturn's overall and I also
want to point out this the lower left
here that these patterns in general for
any obscene of interest that you care
about or for this moduli Indians can be
viewed anatomically and we can't promise
with realizations for being inducing on
the website but what we will be want to
ask is where our most differentially
stable teen fell in these patterns and
that's what his next pie chart is
showing you can see that for basically
all the patterns see the top 10% of
genes it's the most consistent
expression across the brain they fall
into almost all these patterns so that
suggests selected genes as if it's
important for function and whose
functions are not limited to gained
express in a particular region so for
the first part I hope I showed the human
brain atlas provide useful multimodal
resource for studying the adult human
brain these resources come needs to
identify expression patterns of
individual genes but we can use the
entire microarray data sets to find
genes to find the genes that show
consistent ironing between brains also
tend to be important for grooming
functions and for dysfunctions
so that atlas I want to just move on to
it is done a mouse brain atlas this
mouse brain atlas they all get that in a
second I also want to point out some
data from this mouse brain atlas can be
downloaded from application programming
interface I'm not going to talk about
that at all other than to say it's there
and some of the raw data that I'm going
to be using comparisons actually came
from from here but it's the same data
it's
great hours and so some of the key
features of this smack right Alice is
that the genome-wide brain light in situ
hybridisation atlas of the adults smile
frame so there's about 30,000 genes that
are full run almost all of them in
sagittal section and about 4,000 in
frontal sections each of these were then
quantified and mapped onto a 3d
reference atlas which allows comparison
between genes between regions and then
across different mouth frames and that
the state is all available to you and
Selma's online so the way the distress
or commonly is it's to look for a
particular gene of interest in c or
expressed in the brain so for example of
pd h xi is expressed in across a lot of
the grains we can see including
neocortex on the left hippocampus you
can also ask which games are most highly
correlated with a particular gene of its
gene of interest in the brain the juices
of pontification from this inside the
hybridization so it shows a few examples
here of that and then you can ask worse
genes are most highly expressed in a
particular area of the brain so for
example in Mouse cerebellum it's four
can be saw protein two is very highly
expressed in just the Purkinje cells of
the cerebellum
but variable expression 3 much anywhere
else rings so what we wanted to do is to
compare the expression patterns sort of
across many genes in the genome between
mouse and human brain so here you can
see an example of the CDH eleven on the
left in humans and the anatomical format
that I was talking about for displaying
microwaves and in the right for the
quantification and now and so we
hypothesized was if there'd be many
genes such a consistent pattern between
species but that a small number was
differ considerably and there are some
results this has been shown in neocortex
which I'll get to in the next slide and
determining which teams show distinct
patterns enough and humans might be
useful for considering mouse models of
disease
so in the cortex earlier worked from the
Allen students using inside the fibers
ation of about a thousand selected genes
in human and mouse found that about
three-quarters of these showed
consistent patterns between species and
so that's what's shown on the right the
bottom part of this right slide shows
some examples of genes that have high
expression in a particular layer of
cortex in both mouse and human in a
conserved way and some of the ones
towards the tops are examples of in
general a - Desai's marker genes that
began jokesters expression between
species in on the other hand about a
quarter of the genes in one of two
cortical regions and in most cases of
this vertical region shows distinct
patterns between species so that's
what's shown above here some of them
their patterns are different because
they're in different layers in other
cases that have added layers or they
were in hospital felt I explore and rare
cases they switched from excitatory
inhibitory neuron markers and so what we
wanted to look at brain wide whether we
found similar things were resolves genes
that were still very different either
you notice maybe it's for example a
human maybe they're expressed in cortex
whereas and mouse me they're expressing
cerebellum so we did that by basically
comparing our our human the human micro
data to human brain outlets against the
quantification of the you stated hairs
which I'll get to right right now so the
way this works is we first identified
groups of genes with similar expression
patterns in using wDTN a this is what I
talked about earlier he's 32 patterns
that we found then what we did is we
took the each of these very - gene lists
and we found the subset of genes that
were in each of those lists that had
reliable expression in mouse and they're
waiting to find genes with reliable
expression in Mouse is for the
approximately 4,000 genes for both a
sagittal and a coronal series was done
and inside
we took the around 80% of those where
quantifications faith or the federal
informal sectors agreed and so there are
about 2,500 to 3,000 genes that had
since it's an expression in mouth and
also had a micro array of instruments
unzila lead what we did is we as I
mentioned we took for each of the 32
lists we took those sets subsets in with
arrival expression we looked we averaged
the expression and mouse from comparable
regions to the regions that were found
in the human microarray and then we
compared the quantification they saw the
human microarray for those brain regions
against see in situ hybridization
modifications for the same brain regions
and mouse and compares some please
compare both gene groups so 32 groups as
well as individual genes so for
consistent and differential patterns
between species and so when we did this
we found several gene expression
patterns that are highly preserved
between species and many in Medicaid for
these related either in neuronal cell
types or to region specific genes and we
found several patterns that were also
poorly preserved for generally with Lea
and many cases and so this this spot on
the left shows basically a single number
that I'm not going to go into what it
means where is the bigger the number the
more consistent expression there is
between mouse and human
overall for those groups and Don for
example this and six modules should very
conserved expressions associated and you
can see the slightest farfa in the bar
plots the green represents common
expression in alpha he learned the flu
would be human specific expression and
this orange would be in small specific
expression so the pattern overall from
out to human is the same in module six
where it's high in cortex which is so
far as on the left and low in the
subcortical structures with other bars
towards the right on the other hand this
module 30 shows a very different
expression pattern in mouse and human
we're in humans which is a light blue it
tends to be highly expressed as we
release a small subset of sub spiritual
areas and it tends to be lowered for
text for the mouth in the orange it
tends to be higher in cortex and lower
and some of the other structures and the
inset here shows the same sort of a
scatterplot of the same things to see
the high correlations from how to fix in
the low correlation for toddler 30 so
the suggest these patterns as a whole
some of them agree well between species
and some of them agree less well and so
the question is another question that we
wanted assets for the individual genius
in these groups do they all follow the
pattern of the verses of holes for dudes
the different patterns are different
genes in the different patterns - some
of them agree between species and some
of them not a picture of species and so
it turned out that about for all of
these 32 different groups between about
five and twenty percent of the genes and
each groups switched their patterns
between human and L and that's what's
shown on the bottom bar plot down here
the red bars are the ones that switched
their patterns the green ones are the
ones that agree particularly relative
species and others the number degree
particularly well it's sort of dropped
off there are always some that disagree
or that change their patterns what I
mean by changing the pattern is we would
be genes where in human they have a
particular pattern in mouth not only do
they not show the same pattern but
instead they're highly correlated with
different human patterns which suggests
that they are it's not just that we
don't have the tower
specifically to make this experiment
it's that these teams are actually
switching to a different pattern
compared to what they're doing as humans
and this is true even pretty highly
preserved modules so I have a couple of
examples of scenes and sort agree and
disagree the face would use for this
module sex which as a whole is risk for
different modules so these two teams are
left as whisper module show this high
expression neocortex enroller expression
is so cortex one on the right is one
sits in the same group where it's human
it has the same pattern but in Mouse
it's just expressed and it's very
specific um I believe that
the gh3 dentate gyrus for Norrell and
then this module 30 where as a whole
many of the genes an alpha degree like
this one on the right however there's at
least two here sits myelin basic protein
in the CD h-11 where their patterns in
master human agree so overall is that
this map that looks like a youthful
multimodal resource for studying his
adult activity adult mouth frame the
researchers common resources commonly
used to identify expression patterns of
individual genes there's one component
of this research versus the downloadable
expression data for each team it's
mapped onto a 3-d reference Alice and we
were able to identify sets of genes with
highly consistent and with highly
discreet gene expression signatures
between NASA's human brain at the world
anatomical region so this analysis on
similar studies in neocortex and may
provide insight into differences between
massive humans neuro development and
disease okay I'm sure to move on to the
last part of this talk I wanted to talk
about these NIH blueprint not human
primate atlas and so this atlas there
are several key key key features of this
outlets there's an anatomical there's
some anatomical reference data both for
mo MRI and for histology that were done
on the bodies of postnatal samples from
iris others from the study
there's also cellular resolution gene
expression or some sided hybridization
that was done on I believe 46 as the
team's of the session and genome and
then the primary component of the Dallas
is a microarrays profiling of laser
micro dissected samples so this
microwave component includes about 2000
arrays and is very useful because it's
so complete it's very expensive in focus
temporal coverage as well as has
anatomical resolution so there's ten
ages that were example six prenatal and
postnatal with three to four individuals
for age and then there were five brain
regions that were sampled as very fine
as connoisseurs or to cortical regions
hippocampus stratum and it makes a
little bit of our Canadians but this is
very complete and interesting resource
for looking at these these particular
brain regions in us a non-human primate
model you can ask a lot of the same
questions here is it can be asked at
these other ones so for example in the
middle here it's acute mass of a handful
genes on the cross different areas of
the brain in the South different time
and you can ask where they're expressed
you could have switched genes or highly
correlated such as he's reading
differences you can ask different
expressions between different layers of
cortex or the Queen on cortex and
destroy them found many of the same
things I talked about with the other
offices um what we wanted to focus on
was development layers of cortex and so
in this atlas d one component focus was
only planning their development the six
new the six prenatal time points were
chosen as the times of peak neurogenesis
of four neurons for different layers of
cortex and then the sport coat nano time
points were chosen as a sort of a
neonate and infinite juvenile and they
young adults on time point and so this
here in the middle shows a cross section
of the vys neocortex at these different
time points and these color bars show
the basically progression of the
different layers that are available for
laser microdissection at each time and
so the earlier time points there's a lot
of is written sync which works our
progenitor layers which cells that
continue to survive to make neurons
later on and then as time progresses you
get more of these orange and yellow
colors which represents the six layers
structure of the adult cortex as far as
people yes it's our music
seen in adults and so this is a useful
resources for wealth allows us to ask
questions about human neuro development
of projects in a non here in psychic
model system so a little mini primer on
the generation of the cortex excited to
earn our excitatory neurons are
progressively generated for me
progenitor cells in an inside-out
fashion so there's different flavors of
progenitor cells which divide and
initially from the subways I guess we
played with in the replay you get then
the players six neurons are generated
first later on the newly generated layer
five knobs so through the layers and
then are generated in layer five and
later for than later to free so it's
generating inside out fashion before
switching to Leo this is Leo Genesis
sorry
and sort of important things to remember
for this talk are that um these layers
generally consist of different types of
excitatory are neurons so ones and layer
six
many of them are cortical to lemak
projection neurons the ones in lay or
too many of those or falafels projection
neurons so you have different types of
these neurons and four different layers
and also the one farm needs neuron
surface throughout life unlike many
other organs in societies once the
neurons you have on your horns are for
the most part the neurons the neurons
that you have when you die you don't get
recycling as neutrons so and then an
adult these cell types for each of these
layers have known marker genes if you
look at the mouth for an ALICE you can
see mark your chance to lay two three
that are throughout layer two 3s this
top row because you ones that are
definitely subsets of cells in layer two
three
similarly for letter v those are plenty
of smarter team leader stress and all of
the cells or in 50 upper part of layer
fibers are lower
our very first populations furthermore
many of these marketing's are known to
be conserved between species so is there
a market mouse or a marker in humans and
that's part of what I showed on a slide
earlier um one thing that isn't well
understood is whether these genes mark
these cell types from the time the
neurons are formed or whether these are
become marker genes to these websites or
these layers at a much later later time
point
that's what we wanted to look into here
and so the way we did is the way we did
this is we looked at we took a set of
markers at some forty eight months for
the upper layers so we combined layer
two three four layer four four layer 5
and later six we found the sub genes
that were marking those each one of
those layers at eight months which is
basically the adults time points and we
asked at the earlier time points what
percentage of those being also marked
that same layer at those time points and
we can see is that the number of common
marker genes between each stage each
earlier stage and 48 months decreases
with time would suggest for this
emergence of laminar identity of
schedules and so as an example for a
layer six which is his turquoise color
with the number six and twelve month six
there's about 60% of the common marker
genes with adults about 50% at three
months forty percent of zero thirty
percent of you and twenty and twenty
percent of at you 88 90 so this
progressive increase in laminar identity
could be for one of two things
it could either be because when neurons
excitatory neurons are generated they
just look like generic slavery neurons
and it takes some time for them to get
their identities another possibility is
that when they're formed there already
have identity but the genes that are
marking those layers are not the same
ones that are marketable the way the way
we address that question
- look at these layer markers at for all
the time points and to look for genes
that are marker genes for the same layer
and multiple time points and so so
that's what this plot on the Left shows
for layer five it's the set of genes
where in more than one time point it's
marking later five and you can see that
there's a set of genes in early time
points so these are the upper-left one
that's smart layer five early but not
later on there's a set word intermediate
time points they mark layer size but not
earlier or later and then there's these
set of late markers as marfa layer five
in sort of childhood through adulthood
but not at any earlier type lines and
there's a relatively small set of what
we call persistent markers that marks
clarify of across development and so
what this tells up is that these layers
are discrete from formation but that
they're marked by progressively changing
set of genes and there are some examples
that are shown here on the right just it
escapes to work at layer six you can see
this on the bottom row this SLC 26 age
seven at high expression in layer six
but only at you 90-120 for only a
prenatal time this LGR five has high
expressions only from 120 through three
months it ca twelve it was expressed in
layer six primarily but only from 12
months to 48 months and then there's it
fit six which is expressed in layer six
across development so there seems to be
a unique signature for these different
layers across time but that fitted smart
by progressively changing genes so in
summary this outlets
provides a youthful multimodal resource
for studying neuro development in a well
study non-human primate system on this
resource is well-suited for studying
spatio temporal expression patterns of
individual genes we find that the
cortical layers have distinct gene
expression patterns of process
development further the genes marking
each layer change with time
which means that it's the canonical
for adult cortical layers might not be
appropriate to use when studying
developer scientists would have reduced
taken into consideration so overall I
hope I've shown that there are many
useful tools available from the Allens
grandiose data portal for studying the
brain across development since several
species i throw by i provided three
transcriptome wide examples here about
how lead Alyce's can be applied to study
brain development and disease she is
with conserved patterning the brain
first I showed in human the gene was
conserved patterning the brain tend to
be important for brain function and
dysfunction but that the particular
pattern for their absolute expression
level isn't as important in this context
there's also a small a significant
number of diversity patterns genes that
show CG differences which presents an
important consideration when translating
results from out studies to humans
although cortical layers change their
signature Dean's across development
which suggests is important both swear
and the brain you look as well as when
and then I finally wanted to leave you
on the thought that flowey and others
have asked many interesting biological
questions using these Alice's there's a
ton of data here and there's many other
questions that are waiting for you
studies so we encourage people to go and
look up things for yourself and make
your own discoveries using these data so
that's my talk thank you all for
listening this work involves a lot of
people doing a lot of different things
with the elements to them is definitely
not a one or two person house so it's a
very big project so thank you again
thank you dr. Miller for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I'd like to remind our audience
how to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found like clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can
our first question is do you normalize
for cell numbers
the short answer also to the microarray
data is all normalized for the amount of
RNA that's in a piece of tissue it
doesn't so it normal eise's for cell
number in the sense that if you have
more cells in the tissue you're going to
have more RNA and that gets normalized
for the distribution of different kinds
of cells in a particular piece of tissue
is something that is I think a very
interesting other topics but the total
amount of RNA is what gets my life or in
the microwave up for the in situ
hybridization quantification the numbers
represent a combination of the intensity
of staining in cells in a pieces in
tennis in a box or in a little area of
the highest H in combinations with a
percentage of area that's occupied by by
stain so it's a combination of intensity
flux density - it was the number that's
are given out hey next I'm sorry for you
Peggy concluded yes okay your next one
is could you please to find differential
stability so differential stability is
defined as the average Pearson
correlation across brain regions of
genes in a pairwise across brain regions
for the six frames in this study so let
me go back to the slide so for example
what we do is between brains 1 & 2 we
would take the height of each of these
bars in brain Martin's compared to the
height of each of the bars in brain two
and get a Pearson correlation so value
between negative 1 and 1
we then do that for one versus three
longer for longer sides and so on and
then take the average value across six
frames and in fact if it turned out that
the highest lungs were pretty close to
one the lowest ones were around 22 or
0.3 so so it's the average Pearson sorry
this next one is kind of a two-parter
can we knew this bring Alice dataset for
other high-throughput studies and how
authentic and reliable are these
datasets from zero to 100% concur can
you repeat that
sure can we use this brain atlas dataset
for other high-throughput studies and
how authentic and reliable are these
datasets from 0 to 100% reliable enough
ok well so for the first part you can
use these yeah that's for really
anything you want so you can think of I
mean people have compared say blood flow
based on MRI studies in certain areas
the brain against the gene expression
level of genes in similar areas of rain
by matching up the location through the
brain from the reference atlas against
the locations of rain on in these MRI
studies really anything you can think of
that would involve areas of the brain
see some comparative use data again as
for the reliability I mean it's hard to
put a percentage on to it we normalize
the quality just as well as we can and I
think I think we do a pretty good job of
controlling for everything we can think
of what's the raw data as well as the
normalized they are available so if
people think that our reliabilities you
know the way we did it isn't as reliable
as could have been done then you can go
back I think for yourself but I think we
do a good job of either making it as
reliable as possible or in cases where
things don't come out well noting that
on on the website okay and your next one
is can we download this gene data fit as
a user from the Allen website
yes all of the data is downloadable in
multiple forms so my favorite is
typically available by going to the
Downloads tab on whatever Atlas you're
in and downloading it the mouse data you
can download any individual in situ
hybridisation image that you're
interested in by just there's a some
button on there on the image that you're
viewing and then the qualifications of
the sorts of data are available through
the API
in a way that's too complicated and over
the phone but their directions on the on
the API for how to do that okay
um there appear to be no further
questions from the audience so we'll
conclude the presentation today the
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through November 13th 2015
you'll receive an email from lab roots
alerting you and this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
afford that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye